this is very dangerous it'll be fun okay
things are getting hot and crazy in here
we're making sushi we're making sake
well we didn't make sake but we're
drinking sake oh boy
oh god
oh
welcome to night in night out the show
where we compare a home-cooked tasty
recipe to a night out at a fancy
restaurant today we're going on not one
but two dates and then at the end we're
each going to pick which one was the
better date today's episode something
we've never done before we are making
sushi we found a tasty recipe that
allows you to make sushi with cantu i
can't believe that you found something
that incorporates canned tuna i'm gonna
rock it
sushi time do you know how to pick out
an avocado my method is you flick the
nub off okay and if it's green it's not
ready yet i just squeezed the spice test
safe catch that sounds like fancy tuna
sushi right
[Music]
see you in the kitchen
okay sushi time first things first rice
two cups of rice
two cups of water so now we boil that
this is very precarious
sake sake
oh let's go
i'm just gonna see if i needed to go
did you fart
[Music]
that's a dog man i don't know what
you're talking about
you guys i'm
sorry so we want to coat our vinegar
salt sugar mixture over the entire
box of rice
i'm ready to fan fan fan fan fan fans
like your life depends on it ariel i'm a
fan
of me here we have some canned tuna and
we're gonna made spicy tuna a little bit
of sriracha sesame oil and japanese mayo
and green onions that looks awesome yeah
i think the mayo is like your favorite
part of your spicy tuna so we're gonna
wrap our bamboo mats with saran wrap our
rice is not going to stick to this
seaweed uh rough side up time for some
rice okay smoosh my rice this is kind of
fun yeah it's sort of like a craft
project i'm really excited to see what
yours turns out it's very diy right now
like i just feel inspired you ready to
roll you ready to roll yo you write a
round is it perfect no
is it personalized
yes one two three tied in
you know of all the times
next roll is your favorite
in california i love the california roll
yeah maybe the sake bombs kind of are
negatively impacting
our abilities to make sushi right now
yeah but also
more sake bombs
this last one i'm going to be doing a
philadelphia roll and i'm going to be
doing a veggie roll all right this time
i'm gonna make mine an inside in roll
i've got some smoked salmon on top i've
got some cream cheese i put cucumbers
maybe these are the sake bombs talking
but i think by our third attempt we've
gotten a lot better
these are looking pretty nice i've got
it down
i'm going heavy on total all right okay
let's eat
cheers
cheers we made sushi we did it we did it
we had our doubts yes
i absolutely want this california yes
minnie uh-huh
[Music]
that's like cheers i did not think we'd
blow that off this this actually tastes
like something that we bought the
avocado is really fresh and smooth
imitation crab
is very tasty very flavorful the rolls
that are doing really well are the ones
that are tight and the ones that have
all of the bits up next the spicy tuna
roll
[Music]
oh that's spicy oh
oh it's like crunchy oh yeah good spicy
it doesn't quite have the sort of
slippery texture right
yeah like i would buy a cooked tuna roll
yeah i'm gonna do the philadelphia roll
you're doing the veggie roll the veggie
that's a good amount of cream cheese
that tastes just like something that i
would get at first really yeah try it
crack
right
[Music]
oh that's a little spring quartet in my
mouth
[Music]
got a second date to go it's time for
the night out
but first
let's get changed
[Music]
all right sushi number two
we are going to kabuki in hollywood i
feel like we get take out sushi a lot
which is kind of like a hybrid
maybe this should be called night in
night out takeout
[Music]
i'm masa kurihara and i've been working
kabuki 14 years everything comes to
as fresh as possible i've heard that you
actually fly in fish from japan buy from
tsukiji market the biggest fish market
in japan fish has summer lime so you
have to cut against it
that's the best way to do it
should be all consistency the same with
rice
little amounts of deliciousness yeah wow
beautiful
now i'm preparing a cilantro avocado
it's not seaweed
soy pepper
that seems like more rice but it can fit
in there
but then yeah and then he like rolls it
and it just fits
ours might have been too sticky now that
i think this was too sticky wow look at
that
now we're going to cut the upper core so
we're going to decorate up a top of our
roll
[Music]
these are the tricks of the train yeah
it checks in the tray because it might
be stick together so it's a little wet
then before cut
then after make raw i can put on soy
based sauce
it's beautiful
this is a kabuki oil this kind of a
spread rice equally so you can make it
all very smooth
this is a spicy tempura flake wow what
what did you see that
here we go
[Music]
so now we can put the fish on top of it
all
it's a tuna flower tuna flower this is
the roll for this place oh my goodness
wow that is a single roll that is very
impressive
cheers to sushi two days in one day two
days in one day i love dating you
i'm starting with the nigiri sushi roll
my favorite tuna you're going for the
salmon salmon delicious okay you ready
i'm ready okay
i just downed it
this is like perfect little snack like i
can hold in my hand
so let's move on to the spicy cilantro
yellow tail right so we got yellow
got crab we've got cream cheese we got
tempura and cucumber this looks amazing
[Music]
that was so good
[Music]
yeah the white soy paper it just makes
it look so fresh beautiful it's all very
like light and bright this kabuki roll i
don't see how we could do that is it
time it's time
finally oh my god i have been waiting i
have been waiting for this this is not
all gonna fit in my mouth i think i want
this delightful little salmon flower
[Music]
that's so good
it's just like a cascade of salmon i'm
sorry salmon babies
there's probably just popping like oh
okay i'll just spicy tuna oh man spicy
oh boy it's like someone
like taps you on the back yeah and then
smacks you across the face
that was an amazing meal but the
question is ariel which date was better
the night in or
night out so hard overall
yes
what is your final
winner
oh
i think i think my final letter's in my
house
i know i'm always voting for the night
out
i just it's just a fancy maybe maybe i'm
just a fancy lady maybe i just don't
think i'm that good of a cook
the presentation of the fish you know
the chef made us feel really special
it's such a hard decision to make
overall
my winner
was the night in
yes i love the sushi on the night out it
was amazing it was perfect but the night
in just surprised me so much i just
i didn't know
making sushi could be that fun
well thank you all so much for watching
leave us a comment below which one would
you choose for sushi the night out or
the night in and if you make sushi at
home make sure to post some pictures of
your delicious recipe
we will see you next week on night in
versus night out how many sake bombs do
you guys do when you're cooking because
we did for each
we do after okay
[Applause]
would you say this is a good first date
maybe like a third date
oh yes